en estas imágenes se ven los bombardeos
aéreos del ejército Turco en el marco de
su operación bautizada Las garras de la
espada y lanzada en el norte de Irak y
Siria unas zonas que ankara sospecha son
las bases de las fuerzas curvas
consideradas como terroristas por el
gobierno Turco antes de la ofensiva el
Ministerio de defensa tuiteó
ha llegado la hora de la verdad los
sinvergüenzas tendrán que rendir cuentas
por sus ataques traicioneros En
referencia al atentado del 13 de
noviembre que dejó un saldo de seis
muertos e hirió a 81 personas en el
corazón de Estambul las autoridades
turcas habían inmediatamente señalado al
partido de los trabajadores del
kurdistán pkk y el yepegué una milicia
curva activa en Siria como responsables
pero el pkk y el yepegue negaron
cualquier implicación en el ataque estos
kurdos de Siria se manifestaron el
domingo Viven cerca del lugar de las
explosiones
bombardearon la central eléctrica cinco
veces está completamente destruida no
queda nada nos quedamos para sacar a los
heridos de debajo de los escombros
cuando de repente un avión no sobrevoló
y tuvimos que huir
de momento la ofensiva lanzada el sábado
por la noche Solo consiste en una
operación aérea pero Turquía lleva
varios meses amenazando con enviar
tropas a Siria hasta ahora ankara no ha
conseguido la luz verde de Rusia e Irán
Aliados del régimen sirio